Amazing.
All right, guys, welcome to the freaking call.
I've been waiting for this call for a long time.
I know you guys have as well.
First and foremost, I want to let you guys know that and keep, let me know where you
guys are coming from, where you guys are tuning in from.
I'm going to read them here in a second.
And again, as I said, for those of you that just hopped on, as I'm trying to figure out
giveaways, I'm going to try and keep up on the giveaways, Aaron Vogler, I hope you're
ready to take some notes because we're going to be giving away a bunch of stuff today.
But I want to see your names and why you guys did not just spam the comments, but give
some value.
Okay.
Add some value, add some insight.
That's what I want to see.
That's who's going to be getting the giveaway stuff.
Okay.
So a couple of things really, really quick.
Let me make sure I get my notes dialed in because I got a lot going on on my screen
here.
Let's see.
Okay.
Let me just tell you guys really, really quick once again.
So stay on till the end.
This is going to be less than an hour.
So we're going to try to keep it.
We are going to be giving away five coaching calls with Donnie Dre.
We're going to be giving away five coaching calls with the daddy of digital real estate,
Porter, who is just trailing behind Jason, but it's also getting his trash kicked because
Jason's beating him by like 4,000.
Come on Porter, pick it up.
You can't call yourself the daddy if you're getting beat.
Okay.
So five calls with Donnie, five calls with daddy.
We're going to get five swag winners.
We're going to be giving away these t-shirts, the OG digital landlord t-shirts, maybe given
some, I might even give away more than that.
We're going to be doing three winners of the exclusive training library, which is like,
I think it's 14 hours or more of trainings that we did that we did not put in this group.
We're just going to give you the library.
We're going to give three of those.
We're going to give away two partial scholarships, and we're also going to be giving away a pair
of the Apple AirPod Max.
So we've got a ton of stuff to go through, and we are going to be covering a lot, okay?
One thing I want to cover really quick before I bring Ryan Dalton on is if you did not already,
I want you guys to go check out my latest post, okay?
And in that post I mentioned, I said something to the extent of the Facebook group as you
know it has an expiration date, okay?
Why and what does that mean?
I'm not going to be, this isn't going to be a dramatic thing.
It's just going to happen.
I've been saying this for a long time.
People do not value what they do not pay for.
Facts, okay?
Period.
End of story.
You do not value what you do not pay for.
I don't care if it's a freaking soft drink or if it's a course or if it's whatever the
case is.
If it's a vehicle that your parents gave you, when you pay for it, you value it, okay?
That's just how it works, okay?
You get a free training session at the gym.
It's way different than if you pay 150 bucks to be there with a trainer.
You value it differently, and that's just how it's going to work.
So I made a post, go read it, and for those of you that are sitting there and you actually
are serious about this, we have the link in there.
You guys know what you got to do, and I think I even put in the hashtag, you pay the piper
or you pay somebody that's paid the piper, but I just want to make sure this is clear
since we have 70 people on this call right now, that if you wake up one day and the group
is no longer there or it's completely different and you no longer have access, that is why,
okay?
People don't value what they don't pay for.
So if you are somebody that's been sitting on the fence, oh my gosh, I'm not sure if
I should do it, I'm going to have to take a risk, then maybe now is the time, okay?
That's just all I'm going to say about it.
The link is there, and also, you know what I'll do to make it very simple, let me see
if I can actually do this really quick, and then we're going to get into it.
I am going to mute one thing.
One last thing here, let me copy this for anybody that needs it.
There is the link, the digital landlords link, because that's what I posted in the thing,
and no one can tell me that they didn't see it.
I think that's working, okay.
Hopefully that's working.
Yeah, it didn't work.
That's amazing.
Hold on.
That's funny.
Just kidding.
Don't follow that link.
Okay.
That said, guys, let me find this really quick, and then we're going to be bringing on Mr.
Ryan Dalton, and it is going to be a freaking live.
Okay, where the heck is this at?
All right, where the hell is it at?
There it is.
One, two, three, copy, go back here, delete this.
Sorry about that, guys, and yeah, I saw the 404 message.
My bad.
I think that one's going to work.
Still didn't work.
Okay, Aaron, what I need you to do, that's hilarious.
Aaron, I need you to go and find the link.
Yeah, it's not working.
That's amazing.
I love that.
Well, just kidding.
It's too late, guys.
It's too late.
Okay, here's what we'll do.
Watch this.
All right, where the hell is it at?
There it is.
Okay, done.
Now I can do it.
If that doesn't work, you know what I think the problem is?
I think it's just too late.
I think that's all it is.
All right, let's see, paste, and yeah, there we go.
All right, should be good now.
Look at this.
We've got 86 people on, guys.
There, Aaron.
Thanks for jumping in there.
I think that should work, too.
All right, between me and Aaron, one of those suckers is going to work.
If not, then it's just too late.
Okay, there we go.
I think that should work.
Aha.
Boom.
Okay, good to go.
All right, that's all I'm going to say on that, guys.
If possible, pin comment.
There we go.
All right, let's get in the call.
Again, we're going to be, let's give away.
Well, I'm going to bring Ryan Dalton on before we give it away.
Let me give a little bit of a preface, and let's get into today's call.
Guys, stoked about today's call because, let me give a little bit of a
backstory.
Back in 2020, when I was, well, back starting in 2016, as I got into this
business, and I was like, hey, I got to scale this thing, I got to scale
this thing, I got to scale this thing.
As I attempted to scale this business, and I finally was able to scale in
2020, we reached $125,000 in 2021.
That was the max that we reached.
By the way, I think Ryan Dalton's going to come kick my butt here shortly,
which I love.
It's actually the biggest compliment ever.
But anyway, as I did that, guys, I built this business.
I basically felt like I willed it into existence.
I was doing the calls.
I was doing all the sales.
I did have some people, but it wasn't systematized.
It wasn't clean.
It wasn't built properly, okay?
I felt like I had this duct-taped business that was just hanging on by a
thread.
And yes, I pulled it off.
Yes, I willed it into existence, but there was a lot of mess to clean up.
After I hit that number, guys, I went into like a mental funk for like six
months, five to six months.
And you can ask Francesca.
We closed down the office because of COVID.
I was like, inaccessible.
Inaccessible, whatever the case is.
I literally had like, it was weird.
I went into this thing.
I think because I just spent so much energy trying to get to these levels.
My systems weren't dialed in.
I definitely didn't have everything in one place.
My attrition started to kick in, and I just couldn't maintain that 125K.
We were able to maintain the 100K, but the 125 we were not, okay?
I had a business.
I had built a business that only ran with me in the middle, and it was freaking
exhausting.
I had to be there.
I had to run the show.
And the fact of the matter is, if somebody had come to me at that point and said,
hey, I want to buy your business, there is no way I could have sold that
business the way that it was set up.
There's just no way.
Guys, let me just mention some of the tools that I was using at the time to try
and scale.
SCM Rush, 129 bucks a month.
Majestic, 50 bucks a month.
Ahrefs, 129 bucks a month.
Pipe Drive, Entreport, Salesforce, High Level.
These are some of the things that I've tried that worked, didn't work,
whatever.
High Level.
Spent a lot of money on High Level, developing their app, whatever.
Then we got the free stuff.
We got the Google Sheets and the Google Docs.
We got the Asana.
We got Call Rail.
That was a paid one.
We got Google Keyword Planner.
And all these tools, guys, I've never been able to confidently recommend.
Even when I built the training inside Digital Landlords, I just told people what
worked for me, but I told them with a grain of salt, this is what's working for
me now, but use whatever you want.
I couldn't endorse anything because I had no control over it.
I didn't know where the data came from, et cetera.
And I did not have anything that I could recommend.
And that is until now.
Okay?
And so what I'm going to be doing, I'm going to be bringing on Mr.
Ryan Dalton right now, and then we're going to get into this call.
I'm going to explain why we got him on this call and what we've got for you
guys.
It's going to be a real treat.
Okay?
Okay, here we go.
Where is he at?
Ryan Dalton.
What's up, Nick?
Ryan Dalton, we got a full house today, bro.
We got 87 people ready to rip on this call.
88.
How's that sound for a money?
That's a party, man.
I love it, dude.
I love it.
Okay.
So here's what we're going to do, guys.
I want to make sure we give away some stuff really quick.
What I'm going to do, actually, is I'm going to have Jason Allred.
I'm going to have Jason Allred go through, and I'm going to have him select
based.
Here's what I'm going to do.
Anyone that's interested in a coaching call, a quick call with Donnie
Dre slash Porter, I want you to drop, say, me or make a comment that
indicates you're interested.
Okay?
And I'm going to have Jason go in.
I'm going to let him pick 10 winners so we can make sure that we're not
spending the entire time doing the giveaways, even though we're going to
give away all this stuff.
So, Jason, if you are on right now, please indicate that you're hearing
me.
I'll message him as well.
But, Jason, I'm going to put you in charge of picking the 10 people.
You'll have five that go to you.
Five will go to Porter.
Aaron Vogler says, Ryan's closing percentage is so high because of his
hair.
I saw that, yeah.
I love that.
Lean in me, baby.
I love that, dude.
It's so low maintenance.
So, again, Jason Allred, hopefully you're on right now.
I don't see him.
I'm going to send him a, so I don't have to cop off of this.
I'm going to send Jason a quick message.
And then let's get into this call.
I don't see him messaging yet.
So I'm just going to send him a message to Jason.
Hey, bro.
Can you choose?
Oh, he's got it.
He's got it.
All right.
So Jason's going to choose 10 winners.
That's going to be our 10 coaching calls with Porter and Donnie Dre.
Donnie Dre's at 13,600.
Porter's at 9,400.
And these guys are both people that have literally done this with no help
from me.
I've never closed any Porter's deals.
I've never given him a freebie.
He's done this entirely alone.
Okay?
So that said, Ryan Dalton, you ready to get into this?
Yeah.
When do you announce on the Lamborghini giveaway?
That one's coming.
It really depends if we can get a thousand people on.
No, by the way, did you see that that Kai whatever is doing a live stream
for one month?
For a month long live stream.
That's crazy.
He had it.
Yeah, that's a totally I don't even want to know some of the things that came
to my mind when I thought about that.
But yes, a lot of Red Bulls.
Yeah, it's a lot of Red Bulls.
I don't know what's going to happen there.
So, okay.
So, Ryan, I know you're on this call.
I'm going to just do a quick little preface.
Let's get into this.
Okay.
So, guys, Ryan started a little over two years ago.
You guys might have heard the story.
You might not.
Ryan's at $87,000 per month.
Or what are you at right now?
Are you at a little bit?
$87,000.
Yeah.
I got a little bit.
I had some churn.
So I'm between $85,000 and $87,000.
We've got a couple lined up this month.
So we'll see how they go.
So basically, Ryan's on the he's on a run rate right now to do a seven
figure year.
He's already made a million dollars collected into his agency in his first
two years.
But we're talking about now he's on a run rate of a million dollars per
year agency.
And, dude, I have no doubt in my mind you're going to blow my number out of
the water, which, again, is one of it's a compliment.
So I'm stoked about that.
Anyway, Ryan started two years ago.
He wasn't in a weird spot with his job.
He loves his job.
He's got a great job.
It pays him well.
He's got a beautiful house, beautiful family, great, like the perfect
American dream life, the actual American dream.
But he realized, like, hey, well, let me go to the offense.
I'm going to go and find something that I can control.
And he did.
He did his research.
You guys will notice today when you do the call, he's very analytical.
He's a very intelligent person.
And he came across and fell into rank and rent.
Anyway, long story short, two years later, he's scaled to eighty seven
thousand dollars per month.
And this is the most impressive part, guys.
He's kept his job.
He's raised the family.
He still does jujitsu.
He still travels to Brazil.
I still see posts when he's hanging out with his kids.
And it's been amazing to watch.
As I've watched him scale, I remember I would hit him up and be like,
dude, you're crushing it.
You know, and how are you doing it?
And I remember one day because he's a very organized person, very
systematic, he's like, well, let me show you.
And he had put together like these different tools and everything was in
this very neat and organized place.
And I was like, dude, can you do that for my agency?
So he helped me out and he set mine up.
And eventually this conversation came up like, dude, you should build this
for real, where it's an actual product that you can go in.
People can just click a button and then boom, it's it's it's up and running.
And for the past 18 months, it's been about 18 months, right?
Roughly.
Yeah, yeah.
Fifteen.
But, you know, all in conceptualization.
Everything goes through it.
Fifteen months development.
Fifty, sixty thousand somewhere in that ballpark.
Yeah.
Okay.
A lot of blood, sweat and tears has gone into this and it is incredible.
I'm stoked to show you guys have Ryan show you guys this.
So this is I called this live the only tool you need.
And it is the only literally the only tool that I am using now.
It's going to and we're not I'm not we're going to try not to geek out too much
and overwhelm you guys.
But every single one of those tools that I mentioned, the pipe drive tool that I
mentioned that was a CRM that this does that the majestic that tells you how
many backlinks this does that I didn't even mention the SEO quake and the who is
sir like all these different tools.
But every one of these tools that I was using, this will do it.
My favorite thing just as a teaser is doing the due diligence with this tool.
The amount of time this would have saved me when I was doing this is incredible.
So anyway, that said, guys, between the search volume, the ability to buy cheap
numbers through Twilio directly through the platform, the CRM, all of that stuff,
the due diligence tool, we're stoked to show you guys this.
And again, if you'll stay till the end, we're going to be giving away a deal.
We're going to have a deal for everyone that's on this call at the end that wants to
use this tool.
I would highly recommend you say that on top of the giveaways and everything else.
So, Ryan, give us a quick we're going to just quickly do this because I know we've
interviewed you, but give us just a quick anything that I missed about your story
about why you got into this.
And maybe for people that are sitting there, they haven't even started rank and
rap.
Why did you somebody that's a very intelligent person decide that this was the
model that you just said you wanted to get into?
Yeah, man.
Well, first of all, thanks for having me on.
Love being back on the call with the art of digital real estate.
Made a lot of friends out of this group.
So hey, everybody.
Good to be on with you guys tonight.
Yeah.
So why did I get into rank and rant?
So I was looking for something that used the Internet scalable and repeatable
and was actually passive.
And there's a lot of people out there that talk about doing those things.
And this is the model that I found that actually did that.
So, you know, you put up a site, you put in the right market, you rank it, and
you rinse and repeat over and over again.
And the numbers just made a lot of sense.
And at first, I wasn't a true believer until I closed my first deal.
I was like, oh, boy, I can do this.
Like, this is this is a thing.
And then just went from there.
And he really went from there.
Guys, just to put it in context, for those of you that are new, like I saw one
of my my who is a neighbor turned to a friend, Jared Mattson.
He lives in St. George.
Jared, I started if you're still on this call, I started in 2016.
I didn't even make real money until 2020.
It took me four years to start making real money.
Ryan's done this in half the time.
And I think there's a number of reasons.
But one of the reasons I definitely think is because you're very systematized,
you're very organized, you're very like build it, build the foundation.
Correct.
And what we're going to show them today is what was part of and is part of your
your secret sauce, if you will.
So, yeah, dude, let's let's talk about like, I think we just get into it, dude.
I think I don't.
Again, this is the only thing I'm I'm hesitant is I don't want to, like,
overwhelm people.
I just want to show them a few things.
But, guys, this like I just saw somebody like this said, does this replace go
high level a thousand times over?
Dude, go high level is built for like digital whatever.
This is literally ace.
Go ahead.
This is also not a go high level like white label.
There's some people that try to make some tool every now and then, and they
just like put a sticker on from go high level.
This is like this is proprietary technology made for rank and rent by rank
and renters.
So when we made this, it was by me doing the business and then going to other
people who had version one of this and said, hey, what's working?
What's not working?
What do you like?
What do you want?
And people like, you know, like Mike, we used rank and range in one point.
Oh, and, you know, I love that guy.
And he is one of the people that gave me a lot of feedback like, hey, this is
what works.
This is what I'm doing with my agency.
We built something that is made by the rank and rank community for the rank
and rank.
We're not like cobbling together all these tools from all these places where
they've got people to do SEO or people to do website.
There's a lot of general purpose tools.
There needs to be something made by our community that is doing this business
model.
And it just didn't exist.
Right.
And so a lot of people are paying like a lot of like a lot of money to put
together tools that you need, like a piece of it.
Right.
You need a keyword planner.
You need like some element of someone else's tool that is helpful for your
business, but there's a lot you don't need.
So that's what we set out to do.
Right.
We wanted to build the all in one purpose built tool for people that do this
business model by people that do this business model.
Exactly.
And the best products, let's be honest, the best products and services
always come when someone gets into an industry.
They feel the pain points.
They see the pain points and they're like, Hey, I'm going to solve that issue.
Good.
Quick example that we're going to get in and show these guys.
I'm going to use a farming example.
One of the biggest pain points in farming with Alpha Alpha.
Hey, Porter can testify to this is when you when you cut the crop, it's on the
ground, you turn it, it's dry.
You have to wait for this perfect moisture.
Right.
This perfect, the dew has to come in.
And if it's too dry, the leaves fall off.
If it's too wet, you risk it lighting on like catching on fire, sitting in the
stack.
And this company came along called Staley, Staley West.
And they built a freaking dew machine that you literally pull on the back of
your tractor.
And it literally allows you to go in the middle of the day if you want.
And it creates a perfect moisture.
You can bail with a perfect moisture.
And they sell these machines at like two hundred and fifty thousand dollars.
Right.
Per machine.
And they're good.
They're literally selling them like eggs off the shelf because it solved such a
pain point.
But it took somebody in the industry realizing, hey, instead of waking up at 1
a.m. to check the dew temperature and then taking a nap and then checking it
again and doing this every year until you die, let's just create the product.
The best products come from people in the industry that have had the pain, felt
the pain and developed them.
So this is a rank and rent tool just for rank and rent built by rank.
I know there's other people that are building tools.
They're like, yeah, there's a rank and rent.
But you know what they're doing is they're going wide.
They're trying to get the digital market marketers that are doing SMMA and
doing this.
This is for rank and rent.
Done.
That's it.
Why?
And this is one other thing, dude.
That shows you guys how confident Ryan and I are in this in this industry.
Right.
We're not hedging our bets saying, well, if rank and rent doesn't work, we can
go to this other ancillary market or this parallel market.
We are betting our entire futures on rank and rent.
This is built just for rank and rent.
Okay.
So it is catered to rank and rent the way that we do it.
And I'm stoked about it.
So Ryan, I'm going to give you co-hosts.
I think you should just show them the freaking tool, by the way, the version
1.0, which took some setting up and, and, and, you know, duct taping some
tools together was kind of like your, your Petri dish.
You had a 100 people that, that, that did it.
Yeah.
We had like 200 and tune.
I forget the exact number.
It's on my website.
I went and looked at it.
200 and something.
Yeah.
It's 200 and something people that built their agencies, usually 1.0.
And it was so successful with 1.0 that we decided to really polish it and make
it something that's going to be really, really useful for people that doesn't
require all the setup.
So we used to have to do a bunch of no code things to pull some things
together.
And we got rid of that, right?
We just make it point and click kind of thing.
So you want to get into it?
Let's do it, bro.
I'm stoked.
Um, by the way, this is like one of, I don't have that many bookmarks.
This is one of my bookmarks.
Now I wake up, open it up and, uh, and I can see my tasks.
Like, yeah, just show them.
I just gave you co-hosts.
So let's just get in the tool, dude.
All right.
So I'm not, I'm going to say this up front, but we're not going to show you
the whole thing.
Cause we don't have some fun stuff.
We're going to show you some things that are going to make your lives easier
and it would be more fun.
Right.
Cause that's a big part of doing this is having fun doing it.
So.
All right.
Here we are.
So, uh, I'm going to start here and just, uh, kind of talk through what you
see on the left.
We're not going to actually look at all of these cause we just don't have
time for it, but I'm talking about what all these do them to give you guys
some, uh, some due diligence.
So if you guys want to drop a city and a niche into the chat, maybe someone
can keep an eye on it and we can go back and look at some options for due
diligence.
We do some live due diligence here with you guys.
Yeah, guys, let's get some city and niche options.
If you guys have any that maybe you're looking at, or maybe you have a niche
and you want to try a different city, let's do that.
And, uh, while Ryan's getting into it and then once, yeah, let's, let's go
from there.
I'll have some people give some, some examples.
Cool.
So I pulled up a dummy account here.
Um, and I'm going to show you guys, you know, when you log in on this left
sidebar, you can see all the features and this is has what is required to do
this business model.
It allows all of your data to talk to each other in the right way, where you
have efficiency in the way that you build your agency.
So the first is this task tracker, right?
You've got to know what your goals are and you got to have at the task level
things that you're doing to move the needle, right?
It's the best way to describe that.
And then you've got due diligence.
So we're going to dig into some due diligence.
I'm going to show you guys this.
Uh, this is the work and have fun today.
We've got a site portfolio.
All your sites are in one spot, right?
You can just put all the essential things you need to know about all your
sites and what stage development they're in prospects.
You can pull in all your prospect information, what your goals are for your
prospects, your target subscription, right?
It's all right.
Phone numbers, emails, your clients, you pull it on your cloud.
I've got Michael Jackson is my client, right?
Uh, we've got client information in here.
So you've got a CRM, a lead tracker.
So you can't see any doubt in here, but you pull in all your leads.
Um, I've got a little rock concrete, all the calls, call recordings,
uh, you can, you know, annotate them with messages, goodbye tracking numbers.
And the cool thing I love about this, that I love about this is the tracking
numbers you get in rank and run engine.
Uh, you can set up automated SMS for your business owners to get a text
message when the lead comes in, which is the number one retention pool that
I can impress upon you guys.
Uh, and you've got a site analyzer, which I'll show you guys here in a
minute where you can break down your, your sites, uh, getting the SEO
information you need, and then a keyword tool to do manual keyword work.
So let's just hold on Ryan real quick, because I, we kind of brushed
over that.
Yeah.
Ryan is the master at low attrition.
That's how he's been able to scale so rapidly.
His, his attrition is very, very low.
I want you to just say that again about the number one thing that you can do
for keeping low attrition for, for decreasing churn just really quick.
Yeah, totally.
The number one thing, the absolute, I wouldn't even do rank and rent if I
didn't have this feature because I've, I have tested, um, markets where, or
websites that I have not enabled this.
And then ones where I have enabled it and the retention is astronomically
higher.
I don't have a number for you, but it is way, way higher.
And that is the automatic SMS notification when a lead comes in.
So, um, this is the configuration for this number for a little bit.
This is the configuration for this number for Little Rock Concrete, right?
I don't actually own Little Rock Concrete.
That's, uh, I'm sure someone does, but, uh, you have a default SMS lead
notification down here, which basically just says, Hey, you have a new lead
from, and then it'll say Little Rock Concrete and it puts the caller's
number.
So every time that business owner has a call that comes in, a lot of them
don't answer their phone.
That's just the nature of these business owners.
They get a text message that says you have a new lead for Little Rock
Concrete.
They know it came from me.
So they don't think that, Oh, that came from my sources or someone, you
know, gave me that lead.
That wasn't this guy I'm paying for.
They know that it came from me.
And all they have to do is scroll through their text messages to see how
many leads they got in the last month.
And so that's enabled by default with a random retention.
Tell me that, like, I guarantee if that, if there was a tool that just did
that and it costs $20 a month, that people would pay for that.
Yeah.
Just that one little thing.
How many times?
I want you guys, for those of you that have been doing this, how many times
have you had business owners?
You're sending them 30 leads.
You're sending them 50 leads a month.
Even you're sending them 15 and they're, they just sound ungrateful.
And it's, it's because they're, they're ignorant.
They don't even know the leads are coming from you.
This sounds so simple, but literally as soon as I could lead comes in, it's
just that constant reminder.
Oh, that was Ryan.
Oh, that was Nick.
All that was evergreen.
And that was, and that right there will do so much more than a stupid report.
Phone call checking on their kid and it's automated.
It's done.
And that's just one tiny little thing that Ryan was basically skimming over.
I just want to make sure that you guys heard that properly.
So anyway, keep going.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
That retention is essential.
Like that, that is, that is the number one tool that I've used to get to
87,000 a month is they get a lead.
They get a text message.
They know it's from me.
And so everything that comes in every month, I get credit for.
Right.
They're never going to question it.
And I can then use that to keep them.
If they ever call a complaint, Hey, I'm not getting enough leads.
Like, Hey, let's pull up your text messages.
Show me how many you got in the last 30 days.
Right.
And I'll count them.
I'll make them count them.
Right.
One, two, three, four, like, Oh, I got 28.
Like, all right, let's figure out what else is going on because it's not the
lead volume.
Right.
And that's what this tool enables.
You can also do a custom notification.
Right.
And you can also do it like, Hello, you have a new lead from little rock
concrete.
This is evergreen leads.
Thanks for being a great client or whatever, something goofy like that.
Right.
You can customize it.
Amazing.
Okay.
Sorry to stop your stop your flow.
I just had to mention that it sounds like it's just like one little piece,
but it's such a valuable piece.
So let's keep going.
Yeah, totally.
All right.
Just some due diligence.
So this is, this is what I'm like.
This is what I've been geeking out on too.
They're geeking out on it.
This was the most fun part to build.
Like I, this was a lot of hard work, but it was really fun to build this
part.
So we're going to do some due diligence.
We're going to jump in here and do some live due diligence.
And we're going to pipe in some real information in real time.
So this screen is your due diligence.
Empire mapping.
Right.
You've got to know where you're going to succeed and where you're not.
And so what we pull in here.
Okay.
So this is the, this is the, this is the, this is the, this is the,
this is the record.
Automatically when you click a button is all the things that you need to
know to enter a market.
Right.
So I'm just going to point some things out here.
You guys are smart.
You guys can probably read this, but this record right here,
let's just grab one. Let's do like.
This is a paint one.
Let's see.
Hey,
does it let you zoom in a little bit? Can you like,
Plus just to, yeah, I know it kind of skews a little.
That's good right there. That's perfect.
Cool.
Let's do a.
I got it. I got an example too. When you're ready, we can do this one.
We could do concrete contractor, Miami.
Just because everyone's familiar with concrete Miami sounds fun.
It sounds warm.
So that, and Laura's always on the call. So let's do that one.
All right, Laura.
Let's do it.
All right.
So here we're going to click add a record, right?
So we're going to add location and this top right corner.
So while I'm setting this up, we're going to need,
I'm going to tell you guys what we need. All right.
We're going to need, we've got our location, Miami.
We've got our niche concrete.
We're going to need to grab the top three competitor domains.
We'll get those in a minute.
So right now, if you're overseas,
this is only for the United States for now. All right.
We're going to bring it to our buddies over in the UK, Canada,
in Australia.
Right now it's just the U S so your country by default is going to be the
U S.
The state we're in through Florida.
Our city.
We're going to do Miami, but look, here's what you guys need to know.
You guys are marketers. You guys run marketing agencies.
The Miami Fort Lauderdale DMA region is going to capture the greater
Miami region.
This is your advertising region where you're going to have the highest
search volume. All right.
So we're going to pull that in.
Your niche is a lot of niches.
You can add your own if you want to concrete contractor is a,
is a classic.
So it's already in there.
So we're going to put in all of our secondary keywords.
Call driven.
Just a reminder. Like it's gotta be called driven guys.
Primary keywords.
Concrete contractor.
And our school put all of our secondary keywords.
You're going to put in your core keyword list here, right?
These are your pop money keywords, right? So Sam concrete.
Press enter.
Everyone loves concrete drive.
I think just concrete itself too. Right.
See concrete, concrete driveways, patios.
Sidewalks are pretty good ones too.
Concrete.
Sidewalk. All right.
So you've got six core keywords, right?
So Nick teaches you guys to build your core keyword list.
We're going to grab some of those keywords.
Put them in here. These are our money makers, right?
These are the ones with the highest search volume.
Correct.
And then this is the Miami area, right? So a pretty big area.
We know that upfront.
A lot of active businesses, like I don't have to look and I know that.
So we're going to put many, if you're unsure, you can, you know,
Nick's taught you guys.
And me how to do your due diligence when looking at these businesses.
So you can do your competitor analysis.
But here's where the money is going to be made for you guys.
All of those manual entries that you're doing to fill out spreadsheets,
to put in your competitor domain information.
You're, you're not going to have to do that anymore.
So if I do concrete contractor, Miami.
I'm just going to grab the top three domains that I see.
So I'm not going to pull a lot of thought into this,
but I'm just going to grab the ones.
So, and let me say this while you're, while you're grabbing those.
What I, what I've been doing guys.
I have my keyword list.
So I have got my concrete concrete contractor, whatever.
I opened the five, six windows.
And before I start, I just type it in.
I type in concrete Miami, Florida, concrete contractor, Miami, Florida.
All the way down.
And then quickly, I just toggle between all six.
And I go, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
I grab the say, if it shows up in the organic.
You know,
let's say four out of the seven times, four out of the six times.
Boom. That's a top competitor.
I'm dropping it in. It takes an extra two minutes.
That's how I do it to make sure that I'm getting, you know,
the right keywords, right competitors.
But Ryan's doing this off screen just to kind of give you guys an idea.
It takes two seconds, but it takes two seconds.
Yeah, so that's exactly right.
So, you know, you guys want to go look at, you know, which,
which keywords these keep consistently pulling up for,
but we're going to pull it in those domains.
Put them in right here. I'm just going to put in the.
All right.
The root level. All right.
And then the available domain. So you go to go daddy, right.
And whatever brand you're building, whatever your concrete,
whatever you call your concrete brand or your lead generation brand
that you're building, right.
We're just going to go look at that domain and do like concrete
contractor.
Rose Miami.
Right. So it's available, right? We checked. It's available.
And the future we want to see is available.
So we're going to go to go.
Right.
So it's available, right? We checked. It's available.
And the future we want to make it to where you just buy this
straight in the platform,
but you got to make sure that the domain is available.
Well,
we're going to put TBD go or no go put TBD and then you can put
comments here, right?
If you have a further new diligence,
everyone has their own little like take on due diligence.
You can put that in here.
Hey, hold on.
Yeah.
We're counting. Oh, it's done.
I was going to have us count, bro.
The due diligence is done.
That's crazy, bro.
Yeah. Like that. It's done. So due diligence is over for that record.
Right. So here's what we've got here, guys.
We've got, you know,
Up here.
We're indicating this is the name of the domain.
All right.
So it's the first thing that you're building it or your VA or
however you're going to do it. Right.
That's the domain I want.
Like my VA is building it.
Go build this on this domain.
Go buy it.
Right.
Here's our city. This is the DMA region.
So it's the one.
Right.
Here's our city.
This is the DMA region.
So it's the wider area.
Right.
Many active businesses,
concrete contractor,
the population will appear.
DMA region.
So if you do the smaller area,
you can see what the population is,
but you're not going to need that when you do a DMA region,
because it's going to meet your criteria for sure.
Your primary keyword up here.
Right.
And then over on the left, you know,
you can change these to your low-hanging fruit.
Right.
Like yes, no.
Here's the cool stuff.
Right.
Your primary keywords.
The first thing over here on the left search volume of 1300.
I'd say that that that meets the due diligence.
I think you're safe to go into Miami concrete on the,
on the search volumes.
Yeah.
There's enough people looking for concrete Miami for sure.
You see the calls per click.
So seven 70.
For this keyword.
Right.
So pretty good.
And then over here,
your secondary keywords all appear.
So these are all of our money keywords that Nick trained you guys.
Like which are the ones that are going to be your core keywords?
They're all pulled in right here.
And we get the calls per click data that is as fresh as you can get it.
This is as accurate as you can get it.
If you get a not applicable or not known or whatever,
that means that it's just not available in Google.
So we're pulling all that in here so that you can quickly make a decision.
Is there enough search volume?
How much is it going to cost me?
Now I want you to show the competitor analysis.
And then I want to mention a couple of things on this guys.
Well, let me say number one,
number one thing that I love about this,
it saves all the records.
How many times have you guys done a due diligence?
You'll wait three months and you think of a city.
You're like, dude,
I think I did the due diligence on that and you're looking in your Google
drive or worse,
you're somebody like me and you did it on the freaking paper and you're
looking through your folders,
your Manila folders and you're in your little cabinet and you can't find it.
So you go and you spend another 45 minutes.
Everything saved.
You can go look at it in two seconds.
So go through the competitor analysis really quick as well.
Just just quickly.
You can just show these cards.
It's crazy down here.
Yeah.
So what do you grab these top three?
So you got to know who you got to beat to get to the top.
You want to rank organically.
You got to know how you're going to get there.
And so you can look at these top three competitors.
So you put in that domain age, you put in,
you know, you put in their domain, right?
And it's going to spit out immediately their domain age,
how many backlinks they've got, citation flow, domain authority,
page authority and trust flow.
So the essential industry standard SEO metrics just pop right to the top and
we pull in that domain.
So what we're doing is we're using a few APIs to pull that in at the same time.
So when you had to go, it all pops up at once for you.
All right.
So here's better one, two and three better.
Better two has been there for a minute, right?
They're 28 years so that they've been around for a little while.
But you can see like quickly, like Captain Miami concrete contractor,
you can beat that guy like or gal, right?
Like that is not, that is not hard to beat.
So, you know, you can get into that top three and this is what you're able to
surface really quickly when you're able to pull the data into the right spot at
the right time.
Here's another thing I like, guys.
Let's say that you're doing concrete flat work and you decide, you know what,
that you get a new client or you're prospecting a new client and the new
client does a lot of decorative concrete and you want to go and you want to
quickly look in the same city, but you want to look at some different keywords.
Show them how easy it is to quickly edit a keyword and rerun the search.
Yes.
You can just click edit, pop this out.
Like if you wanted to do decorative concrete, add your new keyword, update
the location.
Done.
And there it goes.
All right.
Decorative concrete, $2.00 a click.
I love that.
It feels good.
And that's actually hit the sweet spot, by the way.
So, guys, some people that haven't done the due diligence, like I've literally
personally done over a thousand.
I can, I can definitively say I have done over a thousand freaking, I've probably
done over 500 on a paper.
Right.
And I would like at my prime when I was really good at it.
And I had two monitors and the whole deal, I would get one done in like 22
minutes or whatever the case was.
And I was super stoked, but it was frying my brain.
Right.
We've been talking through this entire thing, chatting on chat.
That took us like all of seven minutes.
And we're not even locked in.
Right.
The amount of time that I have saved on due diligence is bananas.
What it allows you to do is it allows you to look at way more cities.
It allows you to break down way more cities and niche combinations to find that
perfect city.
I mean, dude, just for this, this is the thing that I've used the most and
played around the most with.
And it's just a small part.
So anything else you want to cover on due diligence, any questions that people
have on due diligence.
I saw that there's a couple of things that I wanted to address really quick.
We've got a bunch of people that I recognize in the house here.
Let's see.
Simon says Ryan, Ryan Dalton out here selling shovels in a gold rush.
You know, it's funny about that is yes and no, because Ryan's an opportunist,
but also at the same time, if you can't use that analogy because those people
only sold shovels, this would be like somebody that had the mind that was
making a lot of money, that was making the primary money from the mine and
was like, Hey, I found this shovel that works better.
You should try it too, because there's an opportunity.
So I know what you're saying.
And yeah, there's an opportunity.
We're not going to, we're going to call a spade a spade.
However, Ryan makes his money from doing rank and rent the same way that I
don't make my money from doing the program.
That's not how I made millions of dollars doing the thing, selling and
selling leads, renting simple websites.
Me and Ryan, before we ever opened our mouth about it, we made the million
dollars, the multiple million dollars.
So, but yeah, of course it's a great opportunity.
So Chris says, yeah, I'm in the mine with you.
I'm down there.
We're all in the mine together and I'm tired of having bad tools down in the
mine.
Exactly.
And I'm all about people with good tools.
And if someone wants to come with like a superior sandwich that is dust proof,
whatever, I'll buy that too.
So there's, you know, it's all about opportunity here.
Okay.
Real quick.
Chris says in this example, what stands out about those data points, good or
bad, et cetera.
Let's, let's answer that question and then let's move to a couple of their
features and then give away some t-shirts.
For sure.
Yes.
We'll breeze right through that.
There's some great training on that.
Like I got to give a shout out to Nick's training.
Like he, he dives into all this stuff.
If you're, if you're not taking that, you should, because you can get really
what these metrics mean, right?
These are the metrics that allow you to assess if you have a viable market.
So let's look at this one.
We got up right here, right?
So competitor three is Captain Miami Concrete Contractor.
So you, you have to know what it's going to take for you to beat this
website to rank higher than them.
That's the purpose of the competitor analysis.
The older a domain is and the higher the numbers are in those other metrics,
the harder they are to beat.
So a domain that is less than a year old.
Is way easier to beat than one that's 28 years old.
Right?
So you're able to look at these and say, Hey, am I going to be able to do
what it takes to get in those top three spots or another example?
And we're not going to go through all of them.
You could do a whole hour on just this, but backlinks, this guy has three.
Okay.
You could do three backlinks before this call in, if you know how to do
them, but this guy has 1600.
And so that indicates to me that they'd gotten SEO guy that helps their
concrete company.
Right?
So now I'm battling this SEO guy to be competitor number two.
So each of these metrics will give you insights into what it's going to
take for you to win.
And that's what I'm about.
I want to win, baby.
And I want to win fast.
And so I want to know what it's going to take to do that.
And that's what due diligence does for you.
A hundred percent.
And just so you guys know, also, this is what's so cool about Ryan having
developed this tool is like this, it's not going to be a hundred percent
perfect out the gate.
There's going to be things and we're getting feedback as we go.
We're building like adding changing.
Like one thing I think that would be really valuable.
I've talked to Ryan about is if we had a way that you could click on the
backlinks and it could open up the backlink profile, because we know that
backlinks aren't created equal there.
You could have three good backlinks could be better than 1600.
So we understand that if it's a competitive niche, you might have to go
and you have to analyze those backlinks.
That's something that we can add because Ryan is overseeing the development
of this.
So real quick, I'm going to give away some t-shirts and then let's get into
a couple of the features.
Reggie.
So what I'm going to do, Ryan, sorry, Aaron Vogler, if you're on, please
help us.
And just so you can note who's the winners here, but I'm going to give away
some t-shirts.
Reggie Klassen met Reggie in Sierra Leone of all places back in 2010.
And he's on this call.
I'm going to give him a t-shirt and you can choose which one you want.
What you guys will do if you guys are a winner of the swag, you're going to
message Aaron.
Aaron's going to send you a coupon code.
You go in.
It's completely free shipping and all.
Get your pick your size.
We'll ship directly to your house.
So we got Reggie Klassen.
We've got let's give away.
If anyone stands out to you, let me know, Ryan.
Let's.
Santos.
A t-shirt.
Who?
Santos.
What's the last name?
Garza.
Santos Garza t-shirt winner.
Let's see.
Who else?
I saw a really good comment that I wanted to give because I liked that.
The comments seem good.
All right.
Right here.
Where the hell was we got a lot of comments coming in?
Jason Bertok.
You know, you don't, if you don't ask, you don't receive.
He says he wants a t-shirt.
Give him a t-shirt.
Let's give Jason Bertok.
You know, everyone's going to start dropping that.
Let's see.
Who else we got?
Let's give Morgan Williams t-shirt winner.
Size XL, by the way.
These are great.
Versatile t-shirts.
No, I'm just kidding.
We don't make money on t-shirts.
We don't make shit.
These are just for fun.
I only go shirtless.
Okay.
You know what, Landon, just because of that comment, I think we're going to give Landon
t-shirt.
Landon t-shirt winner.
He just used the reverse psychology, the reverse.
Let's give away one more.
Mason Black says he wears large.
That's an assumptive sale.
Let's freaking go.
Mason Black.
That's t-shirt winner.
There's five.
We'll give away some more guys.
We still have to give away the headphones.
We still got to give away a couple of partial scholarships.
Let's go through a couple more things in our last 10 minutes here.
Ryan.
Yeah, for sure.
All right.
I think we saw a question earlier about data privacy.
Look, no one sees this.
We take data privacy really seriously.
I'm not in here stealing your due diligence.
I've got my own agency planned out for the next year.
I'm not in here ordering your due diligence records.
Due diligence is sacred.
It's your agency building your future.
It's building your rank and run empire.
And so data privacy is something that I'm a very like private privacy
oriented person so that we built the software in accordance with that.
We also are pulling this data straight from the pipe guys.
You're not getting more accurate keyword research anywhere else.
So let me show you guys what I mean by this.
So this is a site analyzer.
And so we're going to do that site.
Let's just grab that domain that was old.
What's that?
C E C O concrete.
All right.
So they've been around a minute.
So you go in here and see like, all right, what am I up against?
And we're going to pull all that information in, right?
We're going to do a little bit more of a deep dive.
So right here from the top, we've got citation flow, trust flow, domain authority and page authority.
Like these are the top four metrics that we look at.
And beneath them, you see our backlinks and backlinks over time.
Give us a picture of how much attention they're putting into being competitive.
So down here, you can see for the year, right, they're working on stacking these backlinks.
Like they got someone that knows what they're doing that's involved.
So that's an indication to me that that's going to be pretty tough.
Right.
And you can see another detail about their backlink information here, where they're referring, all that kind of stuff.
We're not going to get into all that, but I'll give you guys what I mean.
Let's grab this other one.
So if you want to go deep dive captain Miami, that's just a wild name.
All right.
That's like one of those massage parlor type of things.
I'm not sure that's a concrete company.
Yeah, I don't know what that is.
So this guy, look, look, you guys see the difference in these numbers you guys see up here.
We're returning some low numbers, right?
Low backlinks, lost backlinks.
This is going to be easier to beat three referring domains.
You can do a deep dive and look at, hey, are they actually doing what it takes to stay in that spot?
Or can I go win?
So you can analyze all your competition.
You can see their anchor text and referring domains and all that kind of stuff that you guys are probably paying a lot of money for with fancy tools right here with your keyword planner.
This would be a majestic type of a tool, which would cost you $50 per month, just as a heads up.
Now, it doesn't do everything majestic does yet, but that's something that we can work towards with showing, you know, more of the backlink profile and going in a deep dive like that.
But anyway, dope.
Can you show them the the project management piece, which I love?
You know what I love about it?
I'll just pop in there.
Sometimes I'll see something like, for example, we have this GMB that wasn't ranking and it was in one of our locations that we have.
We're making a decent amount of money.
Oh, your screen got smooshed like this.
I think it's just maybe unshare and share again.
It looks like it's like that big.
I don't know.
Just went dark.
I don't know what happened here.
I'm going to come back.
No, try it again.
Anyway.
Okay, that's better.
I'll go in and I went in the other day and I went in.
I put like optimize GMB get three reviews by end of week and I assigned it to Francesca just to kind of piss her off because she basically runs the company and she was humble about it.
She actually didn't even say a word.
She completed the task, moved the card over and it was done.
So anyway, I love the project management task tracker is super nice, too.
Yeah, so I mean, I built this.
I've had over 3000 tasks that we've done in the last year that I write for myself or I write for my team or, you know, I'm big on knowing like what is the actual specific thing that I have to do to move the needle.
Like this is the Hormose thing.
Like what's required and I put what's required into my task tracker.
So you can see that we've got four columns.
Here's what I got to do.
Here's what I'm doing in progress.
Here's what I finished.
And here's where I'm stuck.
And that's the backlog.
Right.
So this is a pretty straightforward project management tool, but it ties in with other agents.
You're not full sheets or Trello or whatever.
You're doing it right here in the tool.
So what's our task?
We need to optimize GVP.
Right.
And then you put in your details where you need to do.
So, you know, add photos, make posts and reply to reviews.
And then you add, you know, whatever you can add images or documents or pictures or videos or whatever you need to add to like, you know, make sure that that task has the data that it needs to be completed.
Assigned prioritization.
This is very high priority.
You can add labels.
Right.
This is GVP optimization.
Probably going to add this one.
So we're going to add a new label.
Right.
I'm the owner.
It's just me.
But you can also have people at sub account users.
So I've got me and then I have my agency.
Nick would have him and then Francesca and everybody else is there.
So you're going to assign them, you know, sub user.
I've got a sub user.
I call them that.
A task is useless without a deadline.
Right.
We're going to do this by Friday.
And then some people like to color code.
And so we just fill up this with everything that we need to do that's required.
Right.
And just chip away at it to move the needle forward over and over and over.
And then that's how the revenue comes in.
Sorry, I'm over here just trying to answer as many questions as possible.
Yeah, I know there's going to be a lot of questions that people have.
One thing that we're going to be doing is a separate Facebook group for
just people that are on this tool.
You can go in, you can ask questions.
There's going to be trainings, et cetera.
Because I know there's going to be a lot of questions, but real quick.
We have that.
Yeah.
You can join my Facebook group.
Right.
So rank and run engine is the Facebook group and you can jump in.
And if you guys want to join that, ask questions or whatever.
I think you were saying that they're asking about that kind of thing.
Yeah.
Well, like I just saw some questions that were very specific.
I mean, we could spend two hours answering questions and they're there.
Some of them are simple questions.
I just was letting them know that there is a Facebook group.
There's ongoing support, et cetera.
What I would like to do really quick though, because I do want to respect
everyone's time and maybe what we'll do is let's announce the winner.
Let's choose a winner of the headphones.
Let's give out the discount code.
I'm going to let everyone know about the scholarship and then let's stay on
for like maybe five, 10 minutes to answer a few questions and then we'll pop
off. That way people that need to go can go.
Just respect that.
Okay.
So we did the t-shirts.
What's the deal?
So what's the deal?
Let's talk about the promo for those that are on this call that join.
I think that we talked about like this will go through at least the next
24 hours.
This promo code that you're going to be giving.
Now there are a few people I want to mention this that may have been in,
you know,
my community inside digital landlords that you guys have the ability to have
you're part of our beta group.
This can they can still like kind of doubt they can kind of double dip and
get this as well.
Correct.
Yeah. They didn't sign up for beta,
which I really appreciate that by the way,
if you were a beta user and you're in digital landlords,
they helped me find kind of the edge cases to work out.
Right.
And I really appreciate that.
That meant a lot to me.
But now we're opening this up to the wider rink and rent community,
starting here as an exclusive and artificial real estate.
And we have a promo code for this group.
That's if all caps landlord 24,
we'll give you 20% off for your first two months of whatever plan that you
get,
or it'll give you 20% off for the year if you wanted to get a plan for the
year, which is a real steal.
That is exclusive for you guys here in artificial real estate.
Landlord 24 all caps landlord, the number 24, right?
That man. Yeah. Yep.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Landlord 24 and join our Facebook group.
It's just called rink and rent engine.
We're in there talking about how to build the agency.
It's a good time.
I love it.
Okay. Two more things.
We mentioned that we're going to be doing two skull,
two partial scholarships for digital landlords.
We're going to be doing two,
And we're going to be doing two,
two partial scholarships for digital landlords.
And we're going to be doing two on that because I want to actually
pick people that I think are going to succeed and have the best chance of
succeeding.
For that one specifically,
if that is something that you are interested in again,
it's just going to be two, it's going to be a partial.
It's not going to be completely free.
It's just going to be two winners.
It's going to be a partial,
but that is something that we are going to be including.
So that's the scholarship piece.
Now, as for the air, the, the Apple,
air pod max there,
I think they're like 580 bucks, something like that.
I've actually never used them, but everyone I know that has them,
loves them.
I don't know if that's cause everyone's just like.
Fanatical about Apple or not, but right.
They're awesome.
Oh, you have them. You have them. Amazing. Okay.
Okay. So there we go. So Ryan, let's,
I think we should ask a relevant question or completely irrelevant.
And based on the answers, let's pick somebody. So let's, I'm going to let you,
whether it's a rank and rent related question,
whether it's a purpose driven question,
whether it's something completely off the wall,
what question should we let people and guys,
what we're going to do is we're going to have you guys,
we're going to give you like one minute answer in the comments.
And from those comments, we're going to be choosing a winner.
Now don't be that person that fricking drops 15 comments or I'm going to not
choose you. Um, what should, what's, what's the question, right?
And by the way, we didn't come in with a plan.
We just thought we kind of go with the flow on this. What should we ask?
You know, you know what I love hearing from people.
I love hearing what their why is.
Why you're what.
A rank in rent agency. What's your reason for doing that?
That I love getting answers to that question.
I love that. So what we're going to do, we're going to take two minutes.
If you've been on this call so far,
we've got 74 people stay on for like four minutes because we're going to be
giving away these Apple AirPods. Um, we don't, we're not,
it's not one of those fixed ones. We've got somebody in mind.
We're going to try and fix this thing. Why are you here?
Why do you want to build a rank and rent empire like Ryan and I have done?
And again, it's, it's amazing. We started out with this idea.
Ryan's scale up to 87,000 a month.
I was able to scale up to a hundred and haven't looked back. Uh,
and we are, we had our wives.
My wife was I wanted to be able to travel the world and make money for my
laptop and give my family and myself experiences that I never got.
And that, that no one got like most people did it. And, uh,
that's what I'm doing. I'm literally in Dubai right now.
I've been able to move my family to Africa twice.
I've been able to literally do exactly what I set out to do.
That was my wife.
And it just, for some reason,
I wanted to scratch that itch and it's still not completely scratched
because I'm still on it, but everyone's is different.
So we're going to go through. You got one minute. Why?
And we're not going to go off with length, but if you, if it's lengthy,
that's fine. Why are you here?
Why do you want to build a rank and rent agency?
Let's see what we got. Okay.
Uh,
let's see, by the way,
I do see some additional questions for the tool.
As soon as we announced this winner,
we're going to spend about five to seven minutes answering a couple more
questions. So we just want to let everybody that needs to get off,
hop off. Okay.
Okay.
Let's see.
Where are we at?
Dude, we got a lot of comments going here.
I love this, man.
We're getting rapid fire. This fires me up.
I know, dude. I love it.
Uh, okay. Eric, it's 3 45 a.m.
where I am setting alarm just to get all these amazing insights have to
work in three hours, but it's still worth it.
Dope shit. Scholarship would be awesome. Okay. Awesome.
Uh, Eric,
Me too, bro. I went to bed at 2 a.m.
4 30. My alarm went off and I, uh,
I even drove to this office space so I could.
Make sure I could scream and not wake anybody else.
Um, let's see.
Where the hell are these?
Why is that? We got a lot. Okay.
Wyatt says, why am I family of five?
Eating.
Uh,
Uh, my wife has celiac is hella expensive.
Okay.
What else?
I'm investment banking.
Hate my job, right?
And I'm going to let you kind of scan through those.
Right.
I'm going to let you scan through those.
I'm going to scan through those.
Right.
I'm going to let you kind of scan through those really quick.
I'm going to let you choose the winner.
This is your show today, bro.
I'm just,
I'm just the,
I'm just here,
the facilitator,
but this is your show.
I'm going to let you kind of scan through.
And what I want you to do,
I want to have you pick the top three.
We're going to do the headphones for the top one.
Uh,
and then I'll give away some swag to the other two.
So at least we have the top three winners.
You see three that you like.
And give this away.
All right.
I got three.
Boom.
Go.
Who are you doing?
Read the answers.
So I,
I like,
uh,
I like Eric getting up in the middle of the night.
Cause he's got a dream.
Like I am all about that.
I love that.
That,
that fires me up.
Uh,
Wyatt,
like if you've got medical things,
nothing makes a man hungrier than something medical in their family.
Right.
I'm going to,
I'm going to solve this.
My wife has,
uh,
gluten intolerance,
right?
She can't eat bread and stuff like that.
It's not celiac,
but,
uh,
that,
that is,
uh,
that's the,
you gotta,
you gotta take serious for sure.
Cause she's gonna have problems later on in life.
I respect that a lot.
And then,
uh,
Katie's talking about her daughters,
I think daughter,
daughters,
two of them.
I got a little girl and I do anything for my little girl.
And so,
uh,
when you arrive home in the middle of the night,
you got medical stuff to solve.
You got,
you know,
little girl,
like those are,
those are the ones that pull on my heart.
So those are my answers for those three.
So,
um,
I vote,
I didn't even see any of those answers because it was going too fast.
But,
um,
Let's,
let's let everyone vote.
Who do you think out of those three winners?
We got Katie with her daughters.
We got Eric.
with Wakin' Up, and we've got Wyatt
with health issues inside the family.
Real quick, who do you guys, let's let everybody vote.
Who's the winner out of the three?
Katie, Wyatt, Eric, just drop a name.
Katie, Wyatt, Eric, we're gonna give,
who won the headphones, two, a couple of people,
pieces of swag, and then we're gonna get
a little bit more Q&A.
What do we got here?
I'm seeing some Katie's popping in.
Katie, Katie, Katie, Katie.
Wyatt, Katie, because same girl.
Gotta go, good stream, Katie.
I think it's Katie, dude.
Yeah, there's a lot.
Yeah, Katie's the winner.
Okay, Katie, you are the winner.
What I'm gonna have you do, and by the way,
Wyatt, Wyatt and Eric, you guys are swag winners.
I know that Eric was also looking at,
talking about a scholarship.
Message me if you guys were interested in the scholarship.
You guys can message me
with why you think you should win it.
Katie, message, Aaron, and we will get you the,
either order the headphones directly to your location
or just Venmo you the money.
You can do it for those headphones, but you enjoy those.
Thanks for being on the stream.
Eric, Wyatt, you guys are gonna win
the Digital Landlord t-shirts,
and you'll get those shipped to your house as well, okay?
Beautiful.
Yeah, Katie, Katie is the clear winner.
I love that, and I appreciate you guys with your feedback.
So let's go, let's do seven minutes.
We're gonna answer a couple more questions,
and then Ryan, let's hop off this call.
But again, guys, I'm gonna type this one more time.
If you didn't already, we've got a code,
LANDLORD24, if you guys want to get the promo,
that's gonna be good for at least 24 hours.
Depending on how that goes, we might extend it.
We'll see, but let's go through a couple of questions
that we had from the actual software side, okay?
But guys, real quick, for those that were on this call,
just wanna say thank you.
We had, I saw at one point, 97 people.
That means a lot to us.
We know you guys have a lot of stuff going on,
and we don't take that lightly.
So I think this was a really awesome call, lots of value.
Got me pumped, it always does.
Every time I'm on with Ryan, I get pumped,
but we just appreciate you guys being on the call.
So just wanted to say that really quick.
For sure, yeah.
Let's see, let's go through a couple of questions real quick.
Kurt Dahlstrom has the best question.
He says, one question you have to ask yourself,
Amex or Visa?
Yeah, assume the close.
I love that, okay.
Okay, let's go.
Justin Taylor says, will there be any form trackers as well,
or just phone calls only?
I think right now it's just phone calls,
but eventually, is there gonna be form trackers?
Is that something on the list?
Is it not on the list?
Yeah, so we do forms, and then we have a lead,
like a forum for inputting the leads,
if you're the one answering the phone,
or if you're a VA, or setter, or however you wanna do it.
Piping in a form through a API call, or a webhook,
from a, like whatever one of your sites are.
Something that we wanna do.
It just is not something that is in this first version.
Keep in mind, guys, this is version 1.0.
There will be many, many versions to come,
but right now, I think for a version 1.0,
this thing is pretty darn robust, in my opinion.
Yeah, we worked really hard on it,
and the cool thing about this is,
you guys are help building this.
So this is something that, as we get feature requests,
this is not a done thing.
As we get feature requests,
we're gonna take those feature requests
that everybody's asking for,
and say, this is what we're building, right?
I have a call every week, with developer,
and you guys help build that vision,
because you say, hey, here's what we want,
and so it's still being built by the rank and rank community,
and it's still an ongoing thing
for development of this platform.
Anthem says, are the sub-users able to log in
with their own login, or do they use ours?
This is awesome.
Yes, yeah, they log in with their own.
You can have your own sub-users.
PJ asks, do we have a call tracking service,
or does this tool does that?
Yeah, this does everything voice.
This is all programmed on auto.
You don't have to use CallRail or any of those others.
It's built all right in here together for you guys.
Dustin says, would you recommend this for someone
just starting out with a couple of sites and no deals yet,
or someone that has deals already?
I'm curious your answer on that, Ryan.
Yeah, absolutely, because even if you don't have
a deal yet, you still have to figure out
where you're gonna build your website.
You have to figure out which market you're gonna win in.
You have to have a phone number
that's gonna put on the website.
You gotta have the tools set up to succeed
once you can close that first business owner.
This is made for everyone from,
I'm just starting rank and rent today,
to I have an agency with 150 websites like I do.
And I think too, and the question also might be
a little deeper, basically asking like,
is it worth the money at this point?
And I think, look, I think the local plan's like 97 bucks
with that discount, you're at 70 bucks.
You have to use something anyway.
You're gonna have to use some kind of tool.
Semrush is 129.
That's just that tool.
But also, I always think about this in terms of time.
If you guys haven't done due diligence,
go do five due diligence and then come sign back up
for rank and rent engine because you guys are gonna wanna
literally poke needles in your eyes.
It is tough.
It is freaking tough.
It takes time.
And from somebody that's literally done
over a thousand themselves, I swear to you,
that feature alone is worth 100 bucks a month.
Like easy for me.
Because I'm saving, dude, I'm saving 23 to 50 minutes.
I bet my first due diligence took me an hour.
So when you're first starting,
you're saving 50 minutes a rip.
You do that for the first 10, 20.
Like what's your time?
Even if your time's only worth 10 bucks an hour,
which it's not, it's worth it just
with the due diligence feature,
which is I think my favorite feature about this thing.
So yes, I think it's like that thing.
Like if you wanna make professional money,
you treat it professional.
However, if you are just completely broke,
then obviously you can go and you can hobnob it together.
Yes.
But again, look at your time and what it's worth.
And sometimes we just forget about that.
So 100%.
Quick question, Casey Patton.
This is actually Kyle's brother.
Good question.
He says, can you create-
What's up, Casey?
I know Casey.
Okay, dope.
He says, can you create recurring tasks?
Recurring tasks.
So like you put in a task and you market it complete
and it comes back up like a month later.
No, we don't have that right now, but that's a great idea.
So when you got it backed up,
yeah, join the Facebook group,
come to our Facebook group.
And then when you guys make an account,
you can actually click your little face up here
and you can click support
and you can put in a feature request.
So you just put in your feature request
and it goes straight into the same tool that I use
to work with my developers to build out that kind of thing.
So that's exactly how the flow works
to get that kind of thing added in.
Dustin says, the task tracker reminds me of Trello
with the cam band board.
Yes, it also like a type drive.
It's so easy to create that card and just drag it over.
Like I used to use Asana and that was like, it was nice,
it was so much that it just overwhelmed me.
This is like a couple of columns, boom, boom, boom.
You're done.
Let's see, what else we got?
Any other questions you see?
Let's answer like one or two more and we'll hop off, dude.
For sure.
More info.
So you guys should know this.
Don't sign up on mobile, it's made for desktop.
So if you're trying to sign up on mobile,
it's not gonna take you to a mobile version of this.
One day maybe we'll have an app or something like that,
but it's designed for desktop.
So I got a question I think about
signed up on mobile earlier
and it's just not built for that right now.
So there's really no reason because, dude,
I don't know about you, I'm not building sites on my mobile.
Like that's just.
Oh, no one is.
Yeah.
So quick question, Landon says,
what kind of spam filters do you offer?
And I know there's something out there.
So we've got under your tracking numbers,
we have built-in spam filtering.
You can enable spam filtering
and that requires them to press one to connect the call.
So they'll have a message that says,
thank you for calling, press one to connect.
And the caller will have to actually input that
on their phone to connect the call, right?
So that's the number one thing I've used to reduce spam.
And you can just enable it by clicking with spam filtering
and update your phone number.
Love it.
I like, dude, how simple this is.
I know that there's other tools that are,
they have a little bit of overlap.
And the frustrating thing for me was that there was so much
because they're trying to cater to SMMA and SEO agencies
and all this stuff.
There was so much that like high level just made my,
I started the Twitch.
It's so specific to rank and rent
that if you aren't in rank and rent,
this stuff wouldn't really make sense,
which I think is the beauty behind it.
Guys, this should show you how confident me and Ryan are
in this fricking industry.
You know, everyone says, how saturated is this?
Well, it's not saturated enough to discourage us from this.
Like this is literally built for rank and rent.
So let's do one more.
Do we still need a call tracking service
or does this call take care of that?
Does this tool take care of that?
Yeah, so all your calls here.
Excuse me.
What's up?
Can you hear me?
Yeah, I got you.
Okay, keep going, keep going.
My internet went out.
Keep going.
I was ready to ride into the sunset, man.
I had it.
I had it going.
Sorry, bro.
Sorry.
I was gonna ride into the sunset.
All right, guys.
So the question is about call tracker.
This is all that you need for programmable voice
and messaging.
So if you're in here, you could buy the phone numbers.
You can find a free number of phone numbers
for your plan, right?
So if you want more than that, you can add phone numbers.
Your phone numbers are free.
And then you set up your right here on the platform, right?
Where you can listen to call recordings.
You can add notes to the call to go and look at it.
It's like important lead information.
All that's done right in here.
You don't have to use any third party service
like CallRail or Twilio or whatever.
Buy numbers in the platform or that you wanna go into
and set them up.
One thing to note,
because I know this is gonna come up.
You currently, at this version,
you cannot port numbers into this platform yet,
but that is definitely a high priority item.
Shit.
Can you not hear me?
Wow.
That's crazy.
I think we lost you, Nick.
Can you hear me now?
How about now?
How about now, Ryan?
If you guys have interest in having an API call being made
like Zapier or something like that,
the data is already in the backend normalized.
So it'd be easy to do that eventually,
but we don't have APIs connected in.
Nick, what was your question, man?
Nick, what was your question?
I'm sorry.
What was your question, man?
We got your back.
Sorry.
We got lucky.
Apparently, my WiFi's a little bit shoddy here,
but I was just letting them know
you cannot port numbers into the software currently,
but that is something that's a high priority item for us
to make sure that's implemented,
but you can buy numbers through the platform.
Yeah, and you can bring in your own number here.
You can select a tracking number or you can add one.
So you can enter your own tracking number right here
so that if you've got another voice system,
you've got some numbers on it,
it's no big deal.
Just come in here, put your number in,
and it's tied into your site portfolio.
And there's no issue with that.
I've got sites that are like that,
that they aren't ported in yet.
And we wanna make it to where you guys can port in
your numbers if you want to,
to get off whatever old platform that you're on.
But in the meantime, you can just put those numbers
right into your site portfolio and tie it up
with whatever site that you're working on.
So would that mean it would still track the leads or no?
It wouldn't show up as the calls.
It would just show what phone number is assigned
to which website right here on the platform,
even if it's like a third-party service.
For sure.
And that is something, guys, we didn't want it.
Again, it's like, let's just get this thing out.
Rather than wait super long.
I was like, Ryan, you should just push this thing out.
So anyway, I think we've gone on long enough.
All caps Landlord 24.
That's the promo code, 20% off for the first two months.
Got the community.
We gave away the swag.
We've got the AirPod Max winners.
And I think that is it.
Ryan Dalton, thanks for being on the call, man.
Yeah, ARTA Digital Real Estate.
Great to be on here with you guys.
Nick, thanks for having me on, man.
I learned a lot from you.
And I'm always deeply grateful for it.
Guys, I'm born and raised.
The first group I ever found about this was,
it used to be called ARTA Pre-Selling.
And it ain't that anymore.
It's all grown up.
And so that's how I got started.
So I found this group.
And two and a half years later,
here we are in different life, different world.
I love it, man.
Well, appreciate you being on.
And everyone go check out the tool.
I know for me, my agency,
it's the only tool that I'm using.
And it's the only tool that I'm gonna be using
from here on out.
So thanks, Ryan.
See you soon.
Thanks. See you guys.